quel message je veux faire passer dans mes photographies d'art,
et à quoi il sert.
De temps à autre, je souhaiterais savoir
comment mesurer l'impact de l'art
comme on le fait avec la médecine ou la technologie
pour lesquelles on peut voir les résultats et les calculer.
Je serais alors capable d'expliquer mon art à ma mère,
avec de réelles données chiffrées.
Mais mon art est si éloigné des mesures.
Par ailleurs, ma photographie expose largement le thème de l'évasion.
Ma théorie, c'est qu'il nous arrive à tous par moments, de tenter de nous échapper
pour pouvoir analyser notre réalité, l'apprécier ou la changer.
Je ne travaille pas sur la vie quotidienne en tant que telle,
et je ne suis pas une photographe documentaire
au sens propre.
Mais, je suis une photographe documentaire
dans un sens différent.
Je documente les rêves.
Je travaille sur la vie quotidienne telle qu'elle pourrait être,
telle que je l'imagine.
Je suis une rêveuse, mais j'aime aussi les choses authentiques
qui ont un rapport avec notre nature profonde
à laquelle jamais je ne voudrais échapper.
J'adore les personnalités compliquées,
et la vraie vie m'incite à créer mes images.
Le monde réel motive notre évasion,
et parfois cette évasion est une réelle nécessité.
Je crois qu'on ne crée pas facilement des héros.
Je choisis de travailler avec des individus qui sont des survivants
faisant face à des routines quotidiennes pas toujours toutes en couleur,
des personnes à la recherche d'une vie meilleure,
en lutte contre les circonstances de la vie.
Pourquoi je choisis de telles personnes comme modèles ?
Parce que j'ai été moi-même dans cette situation
dans laquelle j'ai dû apprendre à survivre dans le monde réel.
J'étais alors une étudiante vivant à l'étranger, à Londres.
Je travaillais à deux endroits en même temps en tant que serveuse.
Bien évidemment, ce n'était pas le travail dont je rêvais,
mais j'avais décidé de jouer à un jeu
dans lequel j'imaginais que j'étais actrice dans un film,
que, dans ce film, j'étais serveuse,
et que je me devais de bien jouer.
J'avais l'habitude de me teindre les cheveux et les sourcils en brun-rouge.
Je faisais des permanentes de cheveux bouclés.
Je perdais du poids,
et je me forçais à croire :
« Je suis juste un personnage jouant dans un film.
Ce n'est pas éternel. Tout cela est seulement temporaire. »
Cela m'a beaucoup aidé.
Cela m'a motivé à changer ma vie
et à considérer une période difficile comme un jeu.
Alors, en tant qu'artiste,
je crée différentes vies pour mes modèles,
afin qu'ils fassent l'expérience d'être quelqu'un d'autre dans la réalité.
À travers le processus photographique,
tous mes modèles deviennent comme des acteurs de films muets.
Ils sont photographiés au moment
où ils croient pleinement être quelqu'un d'autre.
Pour créer une nouvelle réalité dans son intégralité,
je fabrique matériellement tout en détail, dans mon travail,
des costumes jusqu'au décor de la scène quelquefois.
Vu que je fais des photos analogiques
et que je ne leur fait aucune manipulation numérique,
j'ai besoin que tout se passe pour de vrai,
malgré le fait que, de nos jours,
il est possible de créer quasiment tout digitalement.
Je n'aime pas cette voie.
Même si cela atteint la perfection,
je vois la beauté dans l'authenticité artisanale,
et elle est impossible sans imperfections.
Une photo manipulée numériquement n'est pas sincère selon moi.
Elle ne saisit rien de réel.
Ce n'est pas une expérience, ce n'est pas motivant.
C'est comme si, au lieu de voyager,
vous regardiez les photos de voyage de quelqu'un d'autre.
Ce que je trouve si passionnant,
c'est d'être capable de transformer le rêve des gens d'être quelqu'un d'autre,
en une réalité concrète.
C'est comme une drogue qui me pousse à continuer à travailler,
même sans calculs et mesures.
Une de mes modèles
avait toujours rêvé d'être considérée comme une guerrière,
mais elle ne pouvait pas faire du sport à cause de ses problèmes de santé.
Il y a six mois, elle est décédée d'une maladie cardiaque,
à l'âge de 22 ans.
Deux jours avant sa mort,
les images sur lesquelles nous avions travaillé ensemble pendant des mois,
la figurant en guerrière qu'elle rêvait de devenir,
ont été publiées lors d'une grande exposition à Milan par le magazine Vogue.
Toute sa vie a tourné autour de l'idée de vaincre.
Avant de mourir, elle a su
que des milliers de personnes avaient regardé son image du pays de l'évasion
et avaient vu en elle, une guerrière courageuse et sans craintes.
Dans mon travail, j'invite les gens à jouer un jeu
comme nous en avions tous l'habitude étant enfants,
quand nous prétendions être quelqu'un d'autre,
processus qui nous rendait vraiment heureux.
C'est important pour les adultes, à mes yeux.
Nous avons besoin de ces transformations pour appliquer cela au nom de l'Art.
Cela nous donne ce sentiment très réel d'être important et puissant
qui nous permet d'influencer notre réalité.
Je le sais pour en avoir fait l'expérience personnellement.
J'ai eu tellement de versions de moi-même à travers mes autoportraits,
que j'ai été beaucoup de personnages différents.
Être quelqu'un d'autre dans le monde de l'évasion
ne nous donne pas exactement des nombres à jauger,
mais, c'est comme une vraie forme de magie perdue
qui existe mais ne peut être mesurée.
Il y a un pouvoir unique dans l'Art
qui transforme et élève nos limites.
L'Art crée ce que j'appelle « une vie conjurée »,
qui supporte notre existence,
nous pousse, nous motive,
et nous inspire à vivre et à nous exprimer
sans mesures ni calculs.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)